uh hello Roger how are you comrade I
mean France how you doing buddy I'm
doing great
are you a Motorhead fan I don't mind
Motorhead you know I'm more of an Allman
Brothers guy but I could do some
Motorhead ok so you like a southern rock
guy but you can go into heavy metal once
in a while yeah I don't I don't mind it
I'm more in the R&B tradition I like
that Memphis sound what do you and when
you're hanging out with Julian Assange
what do you guys you never met Julian
Assange never spoke to him whitey mailed
with him so I couldn't really say what
is what his musical tastes are you know
I read your explanation that can you
explain it because now I don't like that
it came up again because yes
yeah in the same number your number Gus
they said that when they were trying to
get his emails and he you know had that
meltdown which we'll talk to you about
that he he had mentioned that there were
emails with you and Julian Assange I
believe yeah there except for their art
well let's pick this from the top I
testified as you recall for four and a
half hours behind closed doors for the
House Intelligence Committee remember I
wanted to that to be in public and had
it been right now we'd have no
controversy at all but they're the ones
who insisted that no no we get to malign
you in public call you a Russian agent
and a traitor but you have to answer the
questions behind closed doors and we
won't we won't release the transcript of
that you're not allowed to see the
transcript of that I so I testified four
and a half hours completely truthfully
and I submitted documents per their
request that proved beyond a shadow of a
doubt that not only have I never met
Assange never spoken to him never
emailed with him but I had no advance
notice of the content or the source or
the exact timing of the WikiLeaks
discuss destructing the disclosures that
so thoroughly rocked Hillary's campaign
this is when they hacked the the top
emails and they wound up finding out it
was a Russian hacker
well it's alleged that doesn't act that
is disputed there's some scientific
question about that and but either way I
had no previous knowledge of that never
received anything from WikiLeaks never
therefore passed anything on
Donald Trump or the Trump campaign those
are the indisputable facts and they
don't change now sam nunn bergs comes
out of the woodwork he has a TV
performance that is somewhere between
Howard Beale and networks now that I'm
not going to take this anymore Andy
Kaufman stand-up routine is all over the
place they have something on the
president they have nothing on the
president the president did something
but I don't know what it is and it
didn't know this doesn't lead to the
president I mean Sam it was it was
painful to watch this guy's mental
breakdown he's nailed to you right it's
interesting that you're saying this
because part of his breakdown was
talking about how loyal he is to you
like Jim just said and that you're his
mentor he said yes don't look at any of
the stuff he's my mentor not in trouble
because I love the guy okay Sam we get
it we're in this new journalism let me
tear this works yeah proof and evidence
no longer matter just the charges what's
important the accusation yeah says you
did something completely without
corroboration by the way there are no
emails that prove anything when the
Washington Post calls you and says we
have two people we can't identify and
they say you take up you took a crap in
the woods and they claim that they have
emails that prove you took a crap in the
woods could you comment on that please
the answer is no you can't answer
nameless faceless people I figured out
who they are two witnesses are one of
them is the hapless Sam Nunn bird this
is true Sam when he worked with you we'd
call you 30 40 times a day like what's
going on what's going on Sam don't call
me if you have nothing to talk about
right now what's going on
so one Friday late in the afternoon when
I was trying to get him off the phone
his 45th call that day and he said so
what are you IMPLAN for the weekend I
said the post gets this wrong I said
yeah I think I'll fly to London and have
dinner with Julian Assange
that's throwaway line that's called
stick right that's like when you want to
write money you when you also
it would be like when you opened the
call just now and said hey comrades I
mean hey guys yeah and we went to the
news and said he called his conference
were Russian yeah so anyway my passport
the the surveillance cameras at the
Ecuadorian embassy airport records all
of that would prove that I never left
the country in 2016 or 2015 for that
matter have never met Julian Assange
never spoke to him never he mailed with
him he said now takes that as the truth
yeah and presumably tells the
investigators for the special prosecutor
Stone said he went to London to meet
Asajj now he props up another guy this
fellow remains faceless the post
describes him as a colleague of mine and
another place they described him as an
associate of mine I figured out who it
is he's a virulent critical mind and one
of my worst enemies I guess they don't
do much checking there do you know would
you say his name they described and he
describes an email to the post does he
show it to them that's because it
doesn't exist Roger who is the thing is
is is bogus my name's Roger name hey
guys now what happens is this entire
pack of of bloodthirsty left-wing lynch
mob types Washington Post opinions Salon
Slate Politico Mother Jones and the
absolute worst of them all this odious
drooling creep r-remember on MSNBC oh
wow and they just jump onto this like
it's fact they recycle it so for example
nunberg says in a freewheeling interview
yeah I think Stone might be a subject of
the investigation yeah he's definitely a
subject headline stone the subject of
Mueller probe now that becomes stone
targeted by Mueller it's all mainstream
media lynch mob nonsense it's like
they're like a pack of wild hyenas
nipping at my heels now this becomes the
norm so one of the guys who's the
co-director of that great Netflix film
get me right
your stone heard good things it comes
out on MSNBC it says yeah stone told me
he wanted to meet with Asajj he offers
no corroboration and no proof but you
gotta give the guy credit it got him on
TV and he gets to plug his movie just
before it's up for an Emmy because that
decision will be made eminently
brilliant PR so who's this new of course
yes who's this enemy that that started
this whole thing that people didn't
research from the second person all in
due time my pretty all in due time
okay and also her I have a question a
bit off the subject cuz I think you'll
have an insight into it how much of a
problem is stormy Daniels for the
president because it seems like this is
not going away well I was kind of hoping
that she would challenge Lindsey Graham
for the US Senate because the headline
will Daniel storm Lindsey's log cabin
was just the greatest opportunity but I
don't think she's going to do it you
know what is amazing to me is to care in
other words here we have a situation in
which it appears like the president Road
Dogg deport porn star his wife was you
know was we child right and the
president's approval rating continues to
climb yes a star the economy the
breakthrough in north and so what is
what is the president's approval rating
right now cuz it was they're different
numbers yeah cuz I hear from you that it
continues to climb but then I heard on
the on the news that it's very very low
well look polling is subjective it
depends on the order of the questions
depends on the wording of the questions
depends on the validity and balance in
the sample the two or three polls that I
do kind of watch based on having respect
for their methodology showing the
president hovering around 50 hi I'm Sam
number said 30 but him nunberg said a
lot of things that don't make sense
Wow I mean you can find pollsters that
show them at 30 you can find find
polster's like gravis and
and others that show him near 50 there's
no question that that his poll that his
approval ratings are rising in the face
of all this news in a certain sense
their developments in Korea the the trip
to the border wall these a booming
economy with over two million jobs
created these things tend to be
canceling the stormy Daniels question
out now whether the stormy Daniels
allegations are legally problematic that
I cannot tell you I don't know yeah
because people don't you're I think
people don't really seem to care too
much yeah it's just it's almost like
this is a shock that Donald Trump might
have had second yeah so you've got
you've got this new situation in which
anyone can go out and make an allegation
without corroboration and truth judges
call this hearsay but then you have
numbnuts like re M Elbert sit there and
say well this is legally significant no
it is an re anybody can come on TV and
say anything without corroboration or
proof but that doesn't make it legally
significant it makes it hearsay
now tell me Roger and I'm going based on
your comments because I don't know the
guy
is Sam numbering a little slow on the
uptick no actually he's an idiot savant
he's brilliant by terrific genius he's
an extraordinarily good writer
researcher wordsmith he's a very very
talented guy uh-huh
he's just dealing with his demons he's
guys two demons and he clearly needs
some help but he's not a bad person I
see and he's smoking the media pipe now
so yesterday to get one more day of the
cycle now Sam is on TV saying I told
stone repeatedly I was concerned about
his contacts with WikiLeaks no you
didn't Sam you never expressed any
opinion whatsoever we never discussed it
but hey it got you on CNN so just keep
talking have you reached out to him at
all uh my lawyers have urged me not to
speak to him I don't want to be in a
position of anyone saying oh you were
trying to you know effect the assurance
demony of a guy who might be a witness I
haven't been subpoenaed
there's been no subpoena for my records
but on the other hand not only have I
turned all my wreck
over to the various congressional
committees but back in January of 2017
the New York Times reported on page one
that I had been the subject of a FISA
warrant and therefore I've always
operated on the assumption that the
government has already seen all of my
emails and phone messages text messages
and that's why I can sleep at night you
see I've never met Julian Assange I've
never flown to London to meet him I've
never received anything whatsoever from
WikiLeaks anyway when I said that a
Washington Post reporter writes stone
said he never received anything
whatsoever you notice he didn't rule ow
allegedly hacked emails all on any
covers everything
didn't quite get that didn't number sees
no kicking going on here is a is a
pretty amazing guy rajid number 10 he
was going to rehab to like what happened
with that he did say he was gonna go to
rehab look I hope he finds a
professional help he clearly needs it
he's a talented guide you could have a
great future but he's a Yenta and a
relentless gossip any other now yes have
you talked to Pam Anderson about Julian
Assange cuz she's talked to Julian
Assange and maybe he talked to Pam
Anderson I have not talked to Pam
Anderson but I sure would like to okay
yeah she still it's pretty good she does
it was all terrific he's old another one
of my personal favorites as a matter of
fact wetter than stormy Daniels oh yeah
not even close
oh gosh now what what do you think
happens with with with Assange I mean
does he just say their orders xD
Ecuadorian embassy eventually just toss
them out because I think that a court
said that he has to be arrested I think
that's the key point here why is any of
this significant here's why they claim
it's significant you see if you buy the
idea that Assange is a Russian agent and
that WikiLeaks is not a news
organization but a Russian front
well then under those circumstances
theoretically receiving something from
them passing it on to Donald Trump could
be construed as treasonous the proud
there's two problems with that one
Assange is not a Russian agent just
because the intelligence
agencies say he is that doesn't make it
so these are the people who told us
Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction these are the people who
told us no there's no metadata
collection program for Americans and
then of course Edward Snowden proved
they were lying these are the people who
lied about the Vietnam War these are
people who lied about iran-contra I mean
they lie for a living why would anybody
believe anything John Brennan says this
guy's up to his nose in formulating the
phony dossier that they turned around
and use as the legal rationale for
spying on the Republican candidate for
president so think about that for a
second Nixon has theoretically or
addictions people have eight disgruntled
but privately employed Cubans break into
the Watergate they don't plant bugs that
achieve anything in fact they never
plant any working bugs but it's the
biggest scandal in American history
Obama uses the power and the authority
of the state to spy on Donald Trump and
he uses a phony rationale of misconduct
in Russia based on a phony dossier to
justify it this thing is a setup from
the beginning and somebody's got to go
to jail for it well do you think now you
think government agencies are saying
Assange is a Russian just because what
he's exposing it's a way to kind of
discount what he's exposing as well he's
deeply embarrassed the American
government because he keeps proving that
they lie to us
so she's why they don't like him but in
eleven years that WikiLeaks has been
publishing no one has ever questioned
the accuracy or the authenticity of
anything he's produced you can't say
that about the Washington Post to the
New York Times now and he's gone there
and interviewed him in London several
times does that make Sean Hannity a
traitor
do you worse not do you think he's not a
Russian so their whole theory here falls
apart now I have written and said that
he's not a Russian and made the case
that he's not a Russian he's a
journalist he does what journalists do
which is to get classified or
confidential information from
whistleblowers and publish it that's
what the post does that's what the New
York Times does that's what WikiLeaks
does but I've been saying that for two
years but then you have Ari member say
by Claire declaring that Assange is not
a Russian stone is trying to move the
goal posts so that his actions would not
be considered criminal no I be there are
no actions I never got anything from
these guys never passed anything on but
he's not a Russian either you lose
what's that guy's problem with you why
is that guy so you know I don't like
that he worships Eliot Spitzer that's
his role model I was a Eliot Spitzer I'm
going criminal
oh I see now do you think there's
anything that Assange is sitting on like
do you think there's anything he has
that he knows him Anderson's face no I
think I have no idea I mean I have I'm
not privy to what they know I sure don't
know I'm shocked at the validity and the
impact of some of the stuff that they
have published the guy's a journalist
and I think he's a brilliant one it took
he being persecuted they Trump up these
phony sex sex assault charges in Sweden
those charges are ultimately dropped
because they're a honey trap they were
set up so now he can't leave the embassy
because of the outstanding warrant that
pertains to a charge that's already been
dropped think about that for a moment so
it's just harassment
I think his health is not good the
Ecuadorian Embassy which I drove by when
I was in London this year to speak to
the Oxford Union and the Durham Union
Society and the Cambridge Union which by
the way had a great time with these
students really really interesting this
is a cramped tiny little space that
Ecuador actually shares with Colombia
don't get the idea that Julian Assange
is living in some opulence right he's
living in this cramped little you know
tiny two room or one room who knows a
compartment and he can't leave for fear
that he would be grabbed and extradited
and tried for the crime of publishing
classified information now this is
happening at the same time we have a
movie out the post
celebrating The Washington Post is
publication of classified information
regarding the origins of the Vietnam War
so which is it is this an act of heroism
or is an act there is this a criminal
act
I'd say the media needs to get their
crap together that is true why why are
they allowed to publish classified
things and he doesn't he's a bad guy we
can put it out with you guys
yes Anderson Cooper Erin Burnett Jake
Tapper Chris Cuomo begging me to come on
CNN wait a minute I'm banned at CNN
how could I come on you guys banned me
remember but now they're begging you to
come back wait how does that work what
do you think of of the space force
that's being developed by our president
I'm not I make sure I understand your
question Donald Trump announced that he
wants to develop base force program
called the space force and it would be
for four battles in space for Wars and
and to defend ourselves from threats
both interplanetary and whatever from
the earth and outside the earth and it
would be called actually I'm trying to
to meet a book deadline for my next book
stones rule yes we'll be out shortly and
it's kind of interesting when I went to
the House Intelligence Committee Adam
Schiff I poppin Adam Schiff you know
that guy I don't know no congressman
from California gives gives rise to that
great political slogan if it's Schiff
flush it this guy asks me are you
working on another book I pop in and I
said yes I am he said well we're going
to need the manuscript and I said
excellent it's a men's guide to how to
dress in congressmen I think you could
use it